there are times when like i'm i'm going
to get on twitter one of these platforms
and like i just have to
give myself like a little bit of like
okay we're going in
like yeah like you're putting you're
putting on like
camouflage you know getting on getting
ready to
to go in but yeah i mean i think it's i
think it's hard
it's hard and i think i don't know what
it says about
me that um i'm able to take it
but i you know and the only reason i
think i can is because i don't know a
career
outside of being trolled of course we
didn't call it trolling then but
when i was 15 and became an activist
because i kissed ryan white on tv to
prove that you couldn't get hiv
from casual contact i mean you want to
talk about trolling
i got you i got hate it was a bit
intense i got hate mail
people um were
very threatening in in in person i
didn't get asked to the prom
because you know there were rumors that
i had hiv aids
um so that at 15
you know i i knew it was worth it but
if you have like that sort of prepared
me i think for this
this time where everyone has access
and can say whatever they want to say
about you
and and who you are
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks
actress and activist
alyssa milano joins the conversation
with andrew they talk about what it was
like growing up as a child actress
they also talk about her work in
politics her opinions and whether or not
she's gonna run for congress
the fascinating conversation check it
out right now alyssa milano
on yangspeaks
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks
one of the most prominent activists
in the country uh you probably know her
from her
her in incredible tv career my friend
alyssa milano welcome melissa thank you
so much
thanks for having me and that very
lovely introduction i appreciate it
i appreciate the heck out of you eliza
i'm going to tell a couple of alyssa
milano's stories
so people have a sense of the kind of
person you are
so you and i got to know each other when
i was running for president
and you joined us for this first debate
uh the first debate which was in miami
it was msnbc
uh it was not a great night for me i
didn't get much talking time i came off
the stage
you know like a bit disheartened
thinking like oh like you know i should
have done more
um and you were there and you were just
so
warm and supportive uh and awesome and
like had like zero
uh negativity about you and you were one
of the figures that actually like
uplifted me in the moment i'm not sure i
ever told you that alyssa but
like i i really uh appreciated it
and then months later uh when
coveted hit and i was asking people to
do a message against anti-asian racism
uh you were one of the people that just
jumped on it and said like uh yes
like uh you know i'd love to help um so
these are just two of the examples of
the kind of person that that you are
thank you for saying that and that first
debate was
that was something wasn't it i just felt
i i felt like you had so many important
things to say
and they were purposely not allowing you
to say them
yeah i had the same sense but you don't
have any a frame of reference at that
point because it's just one debate
um but then after like two three four
five six seven debates you're like oh it
really was just that those moderators
weren't very cool
[Laughter]
exactly exactly i still can't believe
that was
uh that was you up there i'm super proud
of everything you've done
since then oh thank you well you you've
been um
an awesome friend and uh ally the whole
time you and i teamed up on georgia
which was
awesome i mean that was like the
greatest thing
[Laughter]
it was nice to win one for a change
wasn't it
it really was yeah you know like i i
have to say that
my opinion about our chances for success
uh went up and down back and forth
several times during the weeks uh before
the vote there were times i was like i
think we're going to win this other
times like i'm not sure we are going to
win
with this i kept texting you and you
would say like one day you'd be like
yeah
feels really good on the ground and the
next day you'd say
yeah i don't think we have a good shot
here
i know and i should have been the
authorities since i was on the ground
uh and you know like um i was highly
subject to all of these
um maddening tv ads
you can imagine what the georgia
television stations look like
oh i know i lived there for two years
when we shot insatiable
and it is it is a really
interesting place and i think the thing
that that makes it most fascinating is
you have
this influx of people from the
entertainment
industry who have come in because years
and years ago
when stacy abrams was in the state
senate
she was smart enough to offer a really
uh
attractive um tax incentive
for productions to come in and shoot
there and so
what that really did was it gradually
made
uh georgia more purple with the more
uh influx of diversity that came in to
work there through the entertainment
industry so it's really
an interesting story on to me like
political migration
like we need to go into all the red
states and put some
some studios in there and get some
productions
going so that we could you know change
all those red states to purple
and then alyssa you hit on it all we
have to do is bring a little bit of
tv production and movie production
anyway look at texas look at texas with
you know with how it turned from from
austin becoming such an incredible music
scene
i mean i think that there might be
something to that i mean
i you know i'm not a sociology uh
professor by any means but i would be
looking into that if
if i were if there is uh you know
because
entertainment industry we're all union
people
you know what else tends to uh result in
blue pockets all this uh is schools
so if you were to start colleges and
college towns
because those are always like the little
blue oasis
in in any state is that the youth you
think
yeah and you know just if you're in that
type of environment nine times out of
ten you tend to be
like uh a bit more uh progressive or
liberal
[Music]
hey are you like everybody who has taken
a mental toll
during covid because i have and my
saving grace has been better help and
this episode of yang speaks is sponsored
by better help and what is better help
it is professional counseling done
privately securely
and simply online if you go to
betterhelp's website you get matched on
a very convenient website that you can
start communicating with professional
counselor in under 48 hours it's not a
crisis line it's not even self-help it's
just professional counseling
done securely online so you can talk
about whether you're depressed or you're
stressed you're
anxious you have relationship issues or
you're not sleeping well or
you're angry for me it's about direction
and i call it my steam valve i just blow
off some steam
once a week and it's freaking fantastic
it's all confidential it's convenient
it's professional
it's affordable i'm a big big big
believer in this
it's time to stop just like tiptoeing
around the fact that we all need someone
to talk to so
listen up i want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener to
yank speaks you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor
yang so join over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp.com
[Music]
i've talked to you any number of times
but i've never actually asked you a
question that has
like been on my mind a little bit you've
been famous since you were very young
like you became a child star um
and it feels like you are the sanest
former child star
[Laughter]
that's a lot of therapy andrew a lot of
therapy it's hard man
i mean and it's hard in the best of
circumstances i think i had one of the
best
experiences because i was
you know on a show for eight years so i
had stability
um my parents had their own lives so it
was never
uh you know a question of them
pushing me into this um
and i recognized that it was important
to be self-reflective at a really young
age
but i'll be honest i i mean i've
struggled with
anxiety and depression and i think a lot
of it has to do with trying to
to figure out what that part of me and
where that part of me lives
as an adult you know and i think i have
this this conversation all the time with
my therapist
about like he'll say to me you know
people
you think people look at you as
a child star but they don't like you
almost have to remind them because
you're so far away from that now and
there's so many generations
that don't know you as that and so but i
do think that there is a lot of my
adulthood where i was trying to
prove that not
only was was it not going to happen to
me where i was going to end up a
statistic
about you know the young child actor
who who winds up being in rehab and
and you know like that i was sure that
that was not going to happen to me and i
made it so
but also that i was worth more than just
being a child actor
you know and and i think any child
prodigy would
relate to that you know i think even
if you played chess and excelled at that
at at a young age
as you grow up there's this thing that
that you don't you got to figure out
what your worth is
as a grown-up and it took me a lot of
years to do that and i've worked really
hard at it so i'm super proud of it and
the interesting thing
thing is once i got to this point where
i was like
yeah i'm a badass you are a badass
alyssa
i didn't want to really act
as much and i'll tell you why because
i feel like i fought for so long
to figure out who i was and to be okay
with that person
that the idea of having to portray
someone else the idea of like embodying
someone who was going through hardship
was really a very weird concept for me i
just did a movie in vancouver
um and it was the first thing i'd i had
done since i
you know since covid page 14
she finds out her sister is dead
so the entire shoot i am
digging so deep for emotion because
i mean that's what we do as actors we
gotta we gotta use what we have inside
of us to invoke
emotion and i i was a little resentful i
got to tell you because i was like
why am i doing this why am i making
myself cry every day i have a job
where it is my job to make people cry
every single day and i have to go to
some dark places sometimes to get
to that point and so the the
the more involved i got in
self-reflection and therapy and
and exploration and all of that it
became
harder and harder for me to to go to
work and and act
it's an interesting it's an interesting
thing and and you know
i think i'm really proud of the work
that i just did
in this movie so yeah it sounds like you
did a great work if you hit with me it
sounds like it was
like you know like you really had to dig
deep so it must have been good
so so i have to figure out like why i'm
still feeling a sense of pride
even though it was so hard for me to go
through it
i mean you know you know there's there's
certain things that we choose to do
that we're like in the middle of it
we're like why did i say yes to this
i've had that thought a couple of times
you know there were there were moments
on the presidential campaign i was like
well like what did i get myself into
again like you know in like uh
um you know week two in the winter away
from the family or whatever it was
you were so brave to do what you did
oh thank you alyssa i mean again you
were there with us uh but
what i i thought to myself in the
beginning was like you know what i'm
going to just do
everything in my power to accelerate the
end of poverty i've got a two-year
window
and just whatever it takes we're going
to do it
and so when things got tough i would
remind myself of that i would just think
about it's like how many
lives can i change you know it's
potentially every once in a while
because i like numbers and stuff i would
even think about i'd be like
i'm fighting for like a trillion dollars
in poverty relief
because there's no way to get there
without the government and uh
you know that the the biggest question i
got on the trail was like where are we
gonna get the money
and then here we are less than two years
later and everyone's like oh yeah we had
the money
it turns out of course they have the
money you know and when you think about
the the places that money goes
instead of other places it's it's
infuriating you know i mean i do a lot
of work for the national endowment of
the arts and we do a lot of lobbying
and i mean the budget this year is
something ridiculous like a hundred and
six
million dollars that's so low
it's so loud a four trillion dollar
budget i was like you know what can we
just
maybe what if we just ask for one dollar
per person for the national endowment of
the arts what if we just tried
you know i don't know let's see what
happens with a budget of you know 380
million right so that we have
one just that's all i'm asking for one
dollar for people to express themselves
because i have this philosophy of like
the first thing
the first inclination that a child has
that we as adults or parents are proud
of them
is what it's a piece of art that we
usually play that's when they draw
something
even my kids crummy drawings alyssa we
stick it up
i have so many crummy drawings of my
kids but you know that's what gives them
their
their self-pride and they're you know so
it is really amazing the things we spend
money on and the the fact that anyone
lives below the poverty line
in this country is infuriating and it
should make every single person mad
yeah i can go through some of the recent
relief bills so
the argument i made when someone asked
me it's like where you need the money i
was like do you remember anyone asking
where we're gonna get the money when we
gave wall street uh trillions of dollars
for the bailout and they were like uh
no and i was like yeah there you go so
the the
uh cares act that came out the 2.2
trillion where everyone got 1200
checks i think that the 1200 checks and
all the money that came to families was
something like 17
of the headline cost like it turns out
we could have given everyone
a thousand bucks a month for six months
with the same amount of money
uh just like 83 this is what you've been
saying for years
yes so just an illustration that you
know we we actually
do have the money did have the money um
but i do feel like
things are coming this direction because
more and more people are like oh yeah we
could do this totally if we just decided
to do so
uh but so it's funny because i do think
that there
are some parallels between um like
running for office which you might do
which we're going to ask you about in a
minute
um but like running for office and some
elements of
um like the creative process uh because
when i was on the road um you know i'd
show up and there'd be a small group of
people
and i'd be like hey i've got this vision
and like you know you're trying to like
engage them and excite them
and and and you're and in my case like i
was genuinely like excited to
to talk to people um but even if you had
a cold or whatnot like you still had to
you know be the show must go on
yeah there's an element of it and uh you
know and then you hope that they tell
their friends and then like the next
time you come back it's bigger and
better uh
and and so there there are some
parallels uh and it you know some of the
overlaps
were it's not great because you can
sense that our politics are kind of
degenerating at the theater
or performative right yeah the same way
i feel the same way about activism
actually
oh my gosh that is probably a hundred
percent correct
that activism has become very
performative
and i think this cancel culture that's
calling people out
culture is an act of uh
of performance and i think that you know
you're a science guy right like the
brain lights up there's certain cortexes
or
whatever they're called that lights up
when you call someone out
on social media and so the reward center
of someone saying oh you know what
that's not uh people are getting
rewarded for that
and therefore they continue to do it and
it is not in any way um
helpful at all so
so yeah so i believe that there's a lot
of activism that's performative as well
i agree uh you know one of the the
things that i see
too is that uh if you are an activist
who achieves a certain level of
prominence and you are
objectively in my view like one of the
country's most prominent activists
um that unfortunately there's like
currency to be gained by trying to
like uh pick at you or dig at you it's
like you know because
if you're you know someone else would be
like oh you know like i can
and that's true for people who aren't
activists too it's like pretty much if
you manage to
undermine someone who people have heard
of then your stuff
can go viral and you can have like a a
moment
like and i do think that there's like as
you said there are reward centers in the
brain that that
um get excited by this possibility um
and it's one of the concerns i have is
that it makes it hard for us to really
achieve sustained action if that the
impulse is to continuously drag down
anyone
who is like prominent enough so that
someone's heard of them
well but i think because of social media
and the fact that everyone has a
platform um
and anyone can really call themselves an
activist
right and and we have i think activists
are looked at
now as celebrities basically
right they're because of social media
they have platforms and they have
you know the bull horn and i think i
think that they get that without
actually putting in the work
and so it is it is something that is
very
hard to sustain you know but i also
think part of me really feels like
you can tell um
who comes by it naturally or
organically you know
who is uh really the essence of who they
are
is living a life of service and those
are the people that
quite often get hit the hardest but are
also willing to say you know what
i'm willing to fail publicly
and make this mistake publicly so people
don't
have to make this mistake again or we
can
we can rewrite the narrative right now
because of my failings
and you know a lot of people's ego won't
allow them to do that
you know and i've i've had to do it many
times in my activism career where i've
said the wrong thing or done the wrong
thing or
you know fought on on something that i
should have
just left alone and and and
i have had to look at it as if i can
if i can be called out and have the
grace
to learn from that experience then
everyone that's watching me
right now is is also learning the lesson
that i'm learning
so wow that's really profound alyssa
uh so you interact with people quite
heavily on social media i mean you
you're um someone who's highly active
um is there a mechanism you use
to remain positive and upbeat um despite
the fact that there is a lot of
uh you know negativity and controversy
on social media because you do
uh kind of have to use it if you're
going to be reaching millions of people
but then sometimes and i'll just speak
for myself i don't speak for myself
like there are times when like i'm i'm
going to get on twitter one of these
platforms and like i just have to
give myself like a little bit of like
okay we're going in
like yeah like you're putting you're
putting on like
camouflage you know getting on getting
ready to go in but yeah i mean i think
it's i think it's hard
it's hard and i think i don't know what
it says about
me that um i'm able to take it
but i you know and the only reason i
think i can is because i don't know
a career outside of being trolled of
course we didn't call it trolling then
but
when i was 15 and became an activist
because i kissed ryan white on tv to
prove that you couldn't get hiv
from casual contact i mean you want to
talk about trolling
i got you i got hate it was a bit
intense i got hate mail
people um were
very threatening in in in person i
didn't get asked to the prom
because you know there were rumors that
i had hiv aids
um so that at 15
you know i i knew it was worth it
but if you have like that sort of
prepared me i think for this
this time um where everyone has access
and can say whatever they want to say
about you
and and who you are and so
yeah you and i are about the same age so
you know we did
come of age pre-social media and then
you know it happened
then we then we we you know we've taken
advantage of its
virtues and uh you know moderated its uh
its downsides
[Music]
[Applause]
okay this episode of yang speaks is
sponsored by athletic greens
i just had this i have this little
awesome athletic greens bowl
i put my athletic green powder in it i
take a scoop every morning put it in
some water
mix it up it tastes delicious and it's
very good for you
it's got 75 vitamins minerals whole food
source ingredients
including a multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend and more
and they all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet increase
your energy and focus
and help with digestion and immune
system and everything you need
in one powder instead of multiple
products so here's the deal
simply visit athleticgreens.com yang and
join health experts athletes
and health conscious go-getters around
the world to make a daily commitment to
their health every day and if you do it
now
they're offering our audience a free
one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs which i do
love so
visit athleticgreens.com get your free
your supply of vitamin d and five free
travel packs
today
[Music]
so i referenced it a little bit earlier
but i have to say i'm like burning up
with curiosity
um where you uh at least
suggested that you might possibly run
for u.s congress against some jerk
representative i don't know him he might
be a very nice man
i don't know him he might be a very nice
man um so yeah so
mclint so i have two homes i have a home
in los
angeles and i have a home in in truckee
and um brad sherman is
the representative for my los angeles
home and this
this guy mcclintock who has been there
for a really long time
is the congressman in district uh four
in california
and so this is kind of how i'm looking
at first of all i get asked
the question when are you going to run
all the time and
i'm kind of looking at this as first of
all it's very
i'm exploring i'm dipping my toe in
and the way i'm looking at it is
i'm sure that no democrat has
has come close in that district or been
able to offer
the dccc data that they've collected
or anything to even get us closer
how red is this district we talking
about plus nine
red there's so much value to be had here
because it's true no one else could
mount a credible challenge uh you could
mount a very credible challenge
and and you would see just like how many
uh
democratic voters are in this plus nine
district because one thing i can say
very very authoritatively is that the
democratic party does not
uh actually contest most any of these
uh clearly republican leaning districts
like if if you were to look at the
recent races
i'm gonna bet that uh you had
essentially like uh
you know like a non-competitive race
like uh you know
like over and over again um and so you
would be a game changer
uh as you can tell i'm positive um i
like this i'm actually looking up
uh mr mcclintock right now whose
political days may be numbered
uh you know and and of course and since
i came out and said that i was
interested in
in maybe entertaining the idea he his
office has released a statement saying
that i have always aligned myself with
radical ideas and
um you know they they love that
that sound bite that all uh democrats
are just
radical liberal extremists they do do a
lot of that i mean when i talked before
about the georgia ads it was like every
ad
was with like aoc the rest of it was
like
john ossoff is gonna team up with aoc
the radical like you're just like what's
going on here it's like a freaking
georgia race and they're
you know that so they'll they'll always
try and tie you to whatever boogie man
let's just figure out let's just talk
about what they are
considering radical ideas right like
that's the other part that is
hilarious to me that the things that
they consider radical
are investing in our communities are
investing
you know in education uh
gun violence prevention like all of the
super radical ideas
no they're the ideas of of why
uh we sent the president took the senate
and you know kept the house in 2020 and
it's
it's we got to do some stuff
i you know alyssa i'm going to go into
full-on uh
persuasion mode here that
i think you're running for congress is a
great idea because it literally might
end up tipping the balance of power
in the house of representatives i mean i
think last i checked like the democratic
advantage is like
five or something like that it's pretty
modest
and so there's a real chance the
republicans
take control in 22
and you would take a non-competitive
district and turn it competitive and
interesting
uh so you know in a way that virtually
no one else could
uh honestly um so uh i'd be into it
uh i you know i know a lot of other
people would be into it so i
like count me in for uh alyssa milano
for fourth district
of california thank you you're amazing
thank you for your support i appreciate
it but i i would like
i would like to start to chip away at
their power in that district
whether or not i win is a whole other
thing but if i could just start chipping
away and give them
give you know hand over and you know i
look at it
i knew john ossoff when he ran for lucy
macbeth's seat for congress in the
special election
right after donald trump was elected and
nobody nobody even entertained the idea
of that district
because it was such a red district and
the groundwork that he was
able to lay not only for his hiself and
his aspirations
but for the sixth district in georgia
he laid the groundwork for lucy macbeth
who is
i mean what would congress be without
lucy macbeth she's incredible
so if i can if i can if i can do that
i think that that would be a very um
exciting
thing to be a part of well i can attest
to the fact that you can
do a lot of good even if the race
doesn't ultimately go your way
so it is true you would end up
identifying new voters
in that district and pave the way
for the next run whether that's in that
district or
and this is interesting too because
you've got a ton of natural
um like political talent alyssa i mean
you've been through so much
like having been through a couple of
these races now like i can see
how you would excel truly um
but but when you come it's talked about
jon ossoff in that race i mean john
ossoff didn't win that race
um but then he ended up in the u.s
senate like not that long thereafter
uh i mean you you have had so many um
experiences that have uh made you into
you know like a really singular figure i
think you'd be very potent
like i certainly would not want to be
your opponent truly
[Laughter]
so um so it's it's highly highly
interesting to me i'm getting more and
more excited about it
uh no pressure anything no problem
brainstormed some ideas and tell me what
you think
um i mean count me into the to whatever
um
you know brain trust you want to form on
this uh and you also did something i'm
super excited about and it's a little
bit premature for me to be talking about
it maybe but like i think you have a
book coming out a little bit later
this year uh is that right i do
i have a book coming out october 26th
and it is
a book of essays um just
basically about how i think of the world
and very personal essays from
you know how i feel about marriage
and childbirth and all of those things
parenting but also oh you know a lot of
political essays of
of um how i see
politics and how i see activism
and mistakes made along the way and
it's very personal and it's very
uh i don't know i loved writing in this
format i had never i've written
children's books and i wrote one book
about baseball
which was kind of like a memoir but i
had never written a book of
essays which is very similar to how i
write
an op-ed right like i write a lot of
op-eds i
feel something about you know a topic
that
is um in the daily zeitgeist and
i'll write an op-ed and writing essays
was exactly the same thing
so there's you know an essay about the
constitution
there is essays about uh you know 18
i was in labor for 18 hours and then
spent
two years two years with
with postpartum depression and anxiety
oh wow that's so hard
it's so hard um and so uh
it was it was a great it was a great
thing to do
during the uh during cove at 19
and during the quarantine because we
couldn't go anywhere
anyway so i really got i i have to
confide this in you alyssa i also wrote
during that time
it was the right thing to do right like
yeah
what did you write they were yeah there
was some deep thinking
um my book doesn't come out until a bit
after yours uh
i i think but it it's um it's about the
lessons i learned on the trail
uh and um the
future of our democracy and like what's
working what's not working
uh media social media it's about
the last several years i was trying to
unpack all the stuff that i'd
experienced which i had
zero time to reflect in the moment every
once in a while when i was running for
president people would come to me be
like hey you should really write stuff
down i was like i have zero
energy right to write anything down
don't you think
that's also like like a little bit of
self
present like perseverance like where
you're
where where you get this
warrior instinct when you're in the
thick of something that should be
[ __ ] freaking you out and so
you have this mechanism that doesn't
allow you to realize what you've done
until you're well enough out of it where
you go oh my god
i just ran for president like they
turned off my mic
like i i'm exhausted you know and i
think that there
is there is
beauty to be found in allowing yourself
time
to then be able to reflect back i love
the process of writing
and to your point i find it to be
immensely cathartic
uh and enjoyable trying to process
something that had happened and i
learned anew
even like you you know you figure you
learn by doing and then
um when you reflect on it though like i
learned again
uh and i felt better about everything
after i got it down on the page which i
i was hoping for
like i hoped that it would be something
where i was
releasing um some thoughts onto the page
or
processing things in a way that would be
helpful and it did work out like that
i mean i got more motivated to alyssa
because
i had a vision and still do for
universal basic income and poverty
relief and cash relief
uh and then i ran for president and took
it as far as i could
um at least in the moment and then you
know we uh
lost um and then i converted into this
other organization
and became like this lobbying org and
then we you know at least got some cash
leave checks out
um but i had like a much firmer sense of
the institutional
landscape and what we would need to do
to actually pass something
big like universal basic kingdom it
could be anything too it could be
many of the things you're talking about
too um you know like common sense gun
safety laws or like you know whatever it
is like you know the things where you
look around
adaptation to climate change um so
uh so so that that was my process
you have to realize and maybe it took
you to write the book to realize it but
your campaign really changed the
discussion
around um well of course universal based
income
but also about data mining um
also just this this
conversation of like how how we need
safety nets and we need hand ups
you know like and ai and the
progressively inhuman economy
and like nobody prepared this country
for a changing economy
like nobody was talking about that
before you you know because it was their
failings
the fact that they did not see this
coming and did not prepare
you know the working class people of
let's say michigan which i think was
incredibly hard hit
um like let's throw your future district
fresno let's throw fresno in there
fresno for sure but how do you not
prepare
people for something with that when you
can see it happening
you can see it it's unfull i mean i
think i saw it in michigan like you know
i spent years
uh working there and and saw the
aftermath of the loss of manufacturing
jobs
and a lot of places still haven't
recovered you know hence
in my opinion donald trump uh you know
at least in some measure
i agree um so uh
so super excited about this book of
essays does it happen uh does that have
a title
uh sorry not sorry is the title
well that's very apt uh also the name of
alyssa's
podcast which you can check out she
interviews
uh leaders and figures from every
area including politics but beyond
politics as well
so alyssa one thing i love about you is
that you're always
grinding on trying to make some positive
changes happen
uh you know whether it's a student debt
um or uh the environment
or guns uh so what are you working on
right now in that space and if someone
wants to get involved in help
like how could they do so well that's a
great question well first of all
i usually post all of the information on
how people can
help on my twitter account and my
instagram
um i'm just starting to get into tick
tock now it is a
slippery slope
but the thing that i am most concerned
with
right now is getting the most vulnerable
uh um
i mean i co-signed on that too i wrote i
wrote an op-ed back in december
talking about the importance of um
of lessening up the patents so that we
can
distribute and manufacture you know
people because i'm a unicef
ambassador so i've i've seen
what a country looks like that has zero
healthcare infrastructure and my whole
thought the whole time is like how are
we gonna get
vaccines in people's arms in you know
the middle of a village in
in india and and that this is such a
different
virus not because it is medically
different
and scientifically different but also
because
we've never had anything like this in a
time when
it only takes 35 hours to be
anywhere in the world you can be in the
most
remote place in the world and be in los
angeles 35 hours later
and so we need you know this
it doesn't no boundaries nowhere is safe
until everywhere is safe so we got to
make sure those patents are lifted we've
got to manufacture as many as we can i
think
you know the fact that the g7 leaders
have committed to
millions and millions and millions and
hundreds of millions of doses it's great
um
and i hope that they use you know these
organizations that are in the ground in
these very vulnerable areas
organizations like unicef that already
have
an incredible vaccine infrastructure in
place
that can get uh this into people's arms
what awesome work alyssa it's awesome i
mean i have family members
in parts of the world that don't have a
vaccine yet so
uh you know like kudos to you on this
work and
what's happening in certain developing
countries is awful and that there's
anything we can do to
help save lives uh so i i love i love
this cause
yeah i think it's important um and it it
really
what else exemplifies more being a part
of a global community
than um taking responsibility for
all of the citizens of the world not
just
those that are live in rich countries
that can uh
whose leaders have hoarded vaccinations
it's crazy how
this has been one of the reason why i
would be so for this alyssa is the fact
is that
right now we're in a different
battle in america which is like the we
have the vaccines we have to like
convince people to get them whereas like
in other parts of the world if they were
there people would be
you know jumping over themselves to try
and uh you know get vaccinated so
i think that's like another very good
reason to do what you're doing exactly
that's exactly right but globally is
wonderful
global global community we all have to
take care of each other
the rich nations must take care of the
most vulnerable nations
um you know what's happening in india
and brazil
and uh nepal it's just it's really
scary and if you're listening to this
please do get vaccinated
it's the right thing i got vaccinated
it's great and please
and please get your second vaccine if
you haven't already because that's the
other thing that's happening in
in the united states we're such a
privileged country that people are like
i just need one
i'm fine get them both
you need both vaccinations i know i will
say i think people know this it's public
i got the johnson johnson so it was like
the one and done
so that that's legit too as far as i
know that's legit too
and you know johnson and johnson should
seriously consider donating
their because they're the other thing
about their vaccine is it doesn't need
the crazy
freezer or refrigeration that these
other needs it seems like a better bet
because then you can just do one dose
like it's uh it's more
portable and a bunch of other things
well alyssa such a joy
such a joy being with you today plea
like anyone who's listening to this
who's blown away by alyssa as i have
been uh
every time i've i've spoken to her do
follow alyssa let's help her
uh her get people vaccines and all of
the other awesome things that she's
working on
uh and also let's keep an eye out for
this book of essays i have a feeling
it's gonna be really
profound i maybe i'll have you back like
after that book's published yeah let's
do it like i can i can uh
read that and then we'll trade too after
i write my book i'll like come on yours
we'll do like a book swap that'll be
fine i love it
i love it well thank you for your time
thank you for your attention thank you
for your kindness
i really appreciate you andrew thank you
i appreciate the heck out of you alyssa
we you know it's been great becoming
your friend
uh and we're just getting started we're
gonna we're gonna do incredible things
i can't wait for all of it thank you
[Music]
you